let's talk about gerrymandering if there
was only one way to repair the state of
representative government in the United
States it would be the elimination of
gerrymandering gerrymandering is a major
hindrance to the functioning of American
democracy
it's never the most discussed issue
because it's not an especially flashy or
exciting topic it's kind of dry it can
be complex you don't often see rallies
against gerrymandering but it's a really
really important problem and it gets
worse every decade the word
gerrymandering was first used in 1812
when the Massachusetts state legislature
redrew state Senate election lines to
favor the Democratic Republican Party
the bill was signed by Massachusetts
governor Elbridge Gerry a Boston
Magazine said one of the districts
looked like a salamander and the hens
referred to this practice as
gerrymandering the u.s. is split up into
435 congressional districts each getting
their own US House representative
federal election law requires districts
to be contiguous not separated by other
districts and the US Constitution
requires that each district have about
the same population so each
congressional district currently has
about 600,000 to 800,000 people living
in it every 10 years occasionally more
often congressional lines are drawn
based on the most recent census
population data to establish the
geography of each district states like
Alaska Delaware Montana North Dakota
South Dakota Vermont and Wyoming are
made up of a single statewide
congressional district because of their
low populations but all other states
have multiple districts and their
respective state legislatures are
responsible for drawing those lines
every individual state also has state
legislative districts each legislative
district within a state elects their own
representative to the state legislature
state legislatures are also responsible
for drawing the state-level legislative
lines whichever party has the majority
in a state legislature be it Democrats
or Republicans usually tries to draw
lines to better suit
spreading their party's voters into more
districts to sway election outcomes
this happens with both federal
congressional districts and state-level
legislative districts within a state
lawmakers get to choose voters instead
of it being the other way around
this is gerrymandering a clear conflict
of interest to serve partisan gain let's
say we have a state where 60% of the
population are blue party voters and 40%
are red party voters and this is a map
of where all the voters live in the
state based on this state's population
let's suppose there must be five
districts if you draw the district lines
straight down vertically like an example
one you get perfect representation the
districts are compact and the number of
blue and red districts are proportionate
to how many blue and red voters there
are in the state so they're likely to
elect three representatives from the
blue party and two representatives from
the red party but an example to where
the district lines are drawn
horizontally the districts are drawn
compactly but you get five blue
districts and all of the red party
voters are disenfranchised example three
is the most like what we have in reality
in a lot of states these districts here
aren't compact they're strategically
drawn into weird shapes and they don't
proportionately resemble the state's
makeup of voter party affiliation you
get more red districts than blue
districts this results in many
legislative and congressional districts
being drawn into strange shapes where
you can clearly tell the lines were
drawn in a strategic way a real-world
example is Illinois's 4th congressional
district this district is also known as
the Latin earmuffs because it connects
to largely Latino areas by a tiny thin
line running down a highway where no one
lives as a result Latinos who are
predominantly Democrats are all shoved
into one district which reduces the
influence that they could have in other
surrounding districts giving Republicans
disproportionate power both Democrats
and Republicans have been guilty of
gerrymandering but a 2014 analysis by
The Washington Post found that 8
the 10 most gerrymandered congressional
districts in the US were drawn by
Republicans and most congressional
gerrymandering in general is by
Republicans gerrymandering by
Republicans after the 2010 census has
put Democrats at a considerable
disadvantage on the national stage and
this is partially why Republicans have a
majority in both houses of Congress
after Barack Obama's 2008 victory
Republicans led an aggressive
state-by-state effort over the next few
years to gain most of the control over
redistricting in 2011 consequently in
the 2012 elections Wisconsin voted for
Obama for president they voted for a
Democratic senator and they cast more
votes for Democrats in their House races
yet thanks to Republican gerrymandering
they elected five Republicans and three
Democrats to the House of
Representatives and maintained a
Republican majority in both state
legislature houses Pennsylvania also
voted to reelect Obama voted for a
Democratic senator and cast more votes
for Democrats running for the house but
thanks to a Republican gerrymandering
the year before they elected 13
Republicans and five Democrats to the
House of Representatives here is what
Pennsylvania's seventh congressional
district looks like which reelected
Republican congressman Pat Mian
ridiculous same thing in Ohio Ohio voted
for Obama elected a Democratic senator
casted out half of its votes for
Democrats running for the house but due
to gerrymandering they elected 12
Republicans and four Democrats to the
house here is oh hi O's first
congressional district that reelected
Republican Steve Chabot to the house
because of Republican victories in state
government elections in 2010 many of
which they won because of gerrymandering
to begin with they were then able to
redraw congressional lines in states
with 40% of US House seats Democrats
redistricted states with only 10% of the
seats and the rest were drawn by divided
state governments nationwide in 2012
Democrats received 1.1 million more
votes than Republicans and House
elections but Republicans won 33 more
seats than Democrats
early does the party that wins the
popular vote for the House of
Representatives not take control of it
and it happened in 2012 in large part
due to gerrymandering on average only
about 10 to 15% of Americans approve of
Congress and how well they do their job
and yet in 2016 only 8 out of the 435
incumbents up for re-election in the US
House of Representatives were defeated
and replaced and the average margin of
victory across all House elections was
37.1% a huge amount a margin of victory
that we often see in countries with
government corruption and only 17 of the
435 seats were won by a margin of 5% or
less only 33 seats were won with a
margin of 10% or less that is to say in
2016 more than 9 out of 10 House races
were landslides where we pretty much
knew who was going to win before anyone
even voted only eight states had House
races that were even remotely
competitive something is wrong with this
if there's one thing that both Democrats
and Republicans should be able to agree
on it's this a 2013 poll conducted by
the Harris poll found that 71% of
Americans across all ideological and
party lines believe that those who stand
to benefit from redrawing congressional
districts should not have a say in how
they are redrawn so what is the solution
well we need independent nonpartisan or
bipartisan non-government Commission's
that draw district lines but it's the
state lawmakers who benefit from
gerrymandering who refuse to pass
legislation that would establish these
Commission's people need to communicate
to their state legislatures that they
are dissatisfied with lawmakers being
able to draw their own district lines we
should also elect democratic state
legislators or at least state
legislators who are willing to reform
redistricting processes but Democrats
are historically more open to
districting fairness and the idea of
allowing independent Commission's to
draw lines nothing will ever change if
the same people who have kept us in this
system are kept in power at the state
level former attorney General Eric
Holder recently signed on as a chairman
of the National Democratic
districting committee not-for-profit
organization that launched in January
the group focuses nationally on
redistricting reform to combat
Republican gerrymandering Barack Obama
has said that he too will be involved
with the organization over the next five
years the NDRC will be fighting battles
in court to make sure that Republicans
aren't violating redistricting laws
they'll be helping the campaign's of
state-level Democratic candidates that
could influence redistricting and
they'll be pushing for state referendums
that would allow voters to approve
redistricting reforms there are a lot of
other private nonprofit state-level
initiatives across the country pushing
for line-drawing to be done by
bipartisan non-governmental commissions
and those organizations need people
support the US Supreme Court will also
rule on partisan gerrymandering this
year a case that could considerably
change the processes of redistricting
throughout the country and even despite
Trump's appointment of Neel Gorsuch to
the Supreme Court there is hope because
conservative justices John Roberts and
Anthony Kennedy might vote with the
courts liberal minority against the
gerrymandering given their records on
similar matters gerrymandering is not
the most frequent issue that legislators
hear from their constituents about make
it an important issue call up your
congressional representative in your
state senator let them know that you
care about redistricting this is most
fundamental as an element of
representative government
tell them you want sensible reform maybe
offer to do something for a non-profit
in your state whose mission it is to
fight gerrymandering I promise you that
one exists when gerrymandering occurs
and the contest for a certain seat in
the US House or a state legislature is
not competitive that incumbent does not
need to earn your vote he or she doesn't
have as much incentive to hear your
voice and govern according to your
interests we're now only a few years
away from our next census in 2020 and
redistricting will follow soon
thereafter in 2021 now is the time to
take action on this issue if you don't
like politicians being able to
manipulate democracy like this